- So I saw the new Star
Wars film this weekend,
(buzzer)
and I've got some issues.
(dramatic music)
Seriously, if you haven't
seen the movie yet,
I'm gonna spoil all of it.
(whirring)
I'm a Star Wars fan.
But I think it's far
from a perfect series.
- Mesa called Jar-Jar Binks.
- And there were a lot of things
about The Last Jedi I liked
like Kylo and Rey taking on Snoke,
puppet Yoda.
But at the same time,
there were a lot of things
I did not care for.
First, the entire Finn plot.
- Where's Rey?
- A lot of the film is
dedicated to this plot line,
and it never works out.
The plan fails,
and its failure has no effect
on the rest of the story.
And seriously, the whole plot
line would've been solved
if Finn and Rose just took a few minutes
to find a parking spot.
Next, Leia Supermanning through space.
Third, and this is a big one for me,
when did Jedi suddenly
have unlimited power?
Rey and Kylo spend most of this film
Force FaceTiming with each other.
And Luke suddenly has the
ability to project his spirit
worlds away from his actual location.
When did these become things?
Fourth, Laura Dern's entire existence.
Why is she in this movie?
And why does her character look like
she fell out of The
Hunger Games Franchise?
Admirable Ackbar should've
been the one that took
control of The Resistance,
and he should've been the one
that went on the suicide mission.
Because that way, we would've cared.
Next, Porgs and Crystal Wolves?
Shut up.
And lastly, the end of the film.
Luke just disappears, really?
Like, I get it,
Luke can't live up to his own legend,
and there's also an argument
for religious allegory,
blah, blah, blah.
Luke is one of the greatest
heroes in cinematic history,
and the guy just fades away into a sunset
because he's exhausted?
(record scratch)
Oh, and Luke milking that cow thing,
what was that?
(playful music)